in january i made a video predicting
five climate change related topics that
you should keep an eye out for this year
now in december let's look back at how
accurate those predictions were and very
briefly review the current state of
knowledge in climate change science and
policy first up my somewhat optimistic
in retrospect prediction about the
postcovid recovery
turns out it wasn't very post because as
it turns out the pandemic is ongoing
it's basically too soon to rule on this
one my concern was that if we follow the
pattern of the last downturn in the
global economy in 2008 that countries
and in particular i was concerned about
china may try to kickstart their
economies with very carbon intensive
projects for example in infrastructure
going back to china i predicted that
they may make some big announcements at
cop26 perhaps related to their coveted
recovery strategy which they didn't but
this year china did make what on the
face of it was quite a big announcement
they pledged to stop financing new coal
power plants abroad and in a theme that
may emerge from this video this is good
but nowhere near enough because while
china did finance 42 gigawatts of
coal-fired power plants abroad in 2020
at home they have a thousand gigawatts
of coal generating capacity so it's
great that they're not building new
plants but at the same time they are by
far and away the world's largest
contributor to coal-based emissions so
let's see if we could do something about
that maybe prediction number two related
to the biden administration and
specifically the georgia senate runoff
which the democrats won and thus barely
rested control of the u.s senate which
is significant because it allows
president biden to push through some
quite ambitious legislature we've
already seen some of this in november
biden signed into law the infrastructure
investment and jobs act that delivered
over a hundred billion dollars to
climate and energy related action so
great first step but that's peanuts
compared to the build back better act
which as of the time of recording is
still being debated in the u.s senate so
while the democrats now control the
senate they only have a majority of one
that means the party needs to be in
total agreement on the wording of an act
before they can push it through so the
built back better act has had some of
its teeth removed it's had some punitive
measures over heavy emitters removed but
as it stands if it's passed then it will
bring biden's ambition of halving u.s
emissions by 2030 within reach which
would be great considering the
proportion of global emissions that the
usa makes up so if it goes ahead very
good news my third prediction related to
cop26 and i made a video about this
relatively recently so check that out
for the full breakdown but i'll
summarize it as
good but
needed to be a lot better i speculated
that perhaps covid would reduce the
ambition of certain participants and it
would just mean that the conference
wouldn't get very much done which i'm
not sure actually happened the thing
which of course made all the headlines
was that india and china watered down
the wording of the final agreement such
that coal was going to be phased down
not phased out i suppose you could argue
that this was done to keep their options
open in a post-covered recovery world
where maybe they wanted to build some
more coal-fired power plants but
that is wild speculation my fourth
prediction related to wildfires in north
america and unfortunately i was correct
in predicting that this would be a bad
wildfire season in may 75 of the western
continental united states experienced
drought conditions and this led to a
wildfire season that started earlier and
as it turned out finished later it's not
to say it was uniform across the board
while in arizona for example things were
much worse than in 2020 california
wasn't quite as badly affected as it was
last year which was really extraordinary
and then my fifth prediction was about
the global average temperature obviously
the year hasn't finished yet so it is
too soon to officially rule on the
temperature anomaly but it's very likely
that 2021's gonna be somewhere around
the fifth or sixth or perhaps seventh
warmest year on record the past seven
years are the seven warmest years on
record the reason why 2021 will not be
the warmest year on record despite the
fact that co2 concentrations are higher
than they have been before is because
co2 isn't the only driver of global
average temperature in particular the el
nino southern oscillation or enzo has a
large role in determining the global
temperature anomaly basically via the
temperature of water in the pacific in
2021 the el nino index remained negative
which is to say that the pacific was
slightly cooler than normal and that
dragged down the global average
temperature but having said that a
global average temperature record was
broken analysis by carbon brief
indicates that 2021 had the warmest
summer on record over land areas which i
guess you could argue is kind of more
representative of the lived experience
of a warmer climate anyway so those were
my predictions of the big climate change
events of 2021 and i think i did okay
but of course it didn't cover absolutely
everything and the really big news story
that i haven't talked about yet is of
course the ipcc's sixth assessment
report specifically working group one's
report being released so this is the
report that looks at the physical basis
of climate change how we understand the
climate system i made a video breaking
down the key takeaways of the report but
to give you just one statistic from it i
think summarizes the whole thing we
narrow down our estimate of what's
called the equilibrium climate
sensitivity this is a number that tells
us how many degrees celsius we think the
planet will warm if we double the amount
of co2 in the atmosphere we now think
that number is somewhere between two and
a half and four degrees celsius with the
likely answer being about three degrees
the reason i bring up this specific
statistic is because
well it's an important statistic but
also because it represents i think the
process that climate change science has
been going through over the past several
years now which is there's a lot of
uncertainty in our understanding of the
climate system but we're narrowing down
the error bars and we are getting a
better and better picture of how the
system works every year this was
formalized if you like by the nobel
prize in physics this year which was
awarded partly to siokoro manabe and
klaus hasselman for their work modeling
the earth's climate and predicting
global warming a real milestone for
climate science this number is also
interesting because it didn't come from
an analysis of climate models on a
computer but instead from a historical
analysis so looking at how temperature
and co2 varied in the past and that's
actually something that i talked about
just last week in a video about the
osmonetil paper that came out in
november this to me was one of the most
incredible papers of the year because it
looked at the past 24 000 years of
temperature data and showed just how
unprecedented the current warming that
we're experiencing is and that the
global climate is currently in a state
that it has simply never been in before
whilst modern humans have been around
amazing stuff definitely check out that
video to learn quite why it's such an
amazing paper so this year scientists
painted an even clearer picture of how
the climate system functions how it
functioned in the past and how we think
it's going to function in the future
so what are politicians doing about it
and what has climate policy been doing
this year well coming into 2021 it was
estimated that existing climate policies
would limit the total global warming by
the year 2100 to between 2.6 and 2.7
degrees celsius it's estimated that if
all countries make their short-term
pledges so pledges by the year 2030 or
so then that warming that we'll see in
the year 2100 will be limited to perhaps
2.4 degrees celsius while if all
countries make their long-term pledges
so getting to net zero sometime in the
second half of the century then that
warming in the year 2100 will be around
1.8 degrees celsius so even assuming a
best-case scenario where all countries
meet all of their pledges we're still
not gonna limit global warming to one
and a half degrees celsius by the year
2100. in fact because the climate system
has a certain amount of lag built into
it we may end up hitting close to two
degrees of warming sometime in the
latter half of the century so once again
while progress has been made the new
pledges this year are definitely good
news they're not aggressive enough
they're not bringing down emissions fast
enough to avoid those really bad effects
of climate change because to round out
this section with another statistic we
are running out of time to try and fix
this problem the co2 concentration in
the earth's atmosphere peaked this
summer at a concentration of just shy of
420 parts per million and that is a
particularly significant milestone
because 420 parts per million of co2 in
the atmosphere represents a 50
increase of co2 concentrations from
pre-industrial levels incidentally if
you'd like to learn why there's an
annual cycle in this graph along with a
whole bunch of other stuff to do with it
then perhaps you should pre-order my
book firmament it's about the
development of atmospheric science it's
out in january and the link is below so
that was my ultra rapid roundup of the
big climate change news from this year
but what can we expect to happen next
year
i have three predictions prediction one
climate finance at cop27 these
conference of the parties events are
meant to happen every year we just
didn't have one in 2020 because of the
pandemic so next year in egypt in cop27
there's going to be lots to unpack from
cop26 i predict that money is going to
be the big talking point of 27
specifically money in relation to the
phase down not out of coal if countries
in the global north are insisting that
countries in the global south don't
develop using coal then there's going to
be an extra price to pay in association
with that and who is going to pay
where does the money go who gets to
decide we may also see talk of a new
finance system to help countries that
have been hit by weather events made
more extreme by climate change and
frankly all of these conversations are
long overdue and maybe we'll see some
new pledges come in that will lower the
amount of warming expected by 2100 to
one and a half degrees though i'm not
holding my breath on that one prediction
number two the sixth assessment reports
work in groups two and three the sixth
assessment report isn't finished yet
we've only seen working group one's
report we still have working group two
which is about the expected impacts of
climate change and work in group three's
report which is going to be about
mitigation of climate change to come
both are expected next year my
prediction is that geopolitical sparks
will fly when working group two released
their report because remember that the
impacts of climate change are not
uniformly distributed and the
populations of some countries are going
to get a nasty shock next year when they
learn that the outlook for the 21st
century isn't that great for where they
live and we may see the rise of a quite
insular way of looking at the world and
people closing off their borders and
saying that migrants are not welcome and
that is only gonna heighten geopolitical
tensions also when working group three
released their report i predict we are
going to see some hilarious tech bro
takes on how to mitigate and prevent
climate change perhaps specifically
actually in regards to carbon capture
please don't get taken in by them and
finally prediction number three a
temperature record i was wrong on this
front this year but the el nino index
cannot stay negative forever and the
current outlook is that it's more likely
than not to become at least neutral in
spring next year without the effect of
cooler pacific waters masking the
overall warming signal we could well see
a record set for global average
temperature in 2022 though unfortunately
this is a prediction i could make for
most of the years in the coming century
and
probably
be correct perhaps i'll do one of these
recaps every year let me know in the
comments if you found this ultra rapid
roundup of the big climate stories
useful or interesting though if you
would like weekly coverage of this kind
of thing then i've already mentioned
them carbon brief is an excellent source
as is the youtube channel just have a
think i'll leave links to both of them
down below perhaps i'll be back next
christmas with an evaluation of how
accurate my predictions were this time
now this year instead of doing christmas
presents my family has nominated
charities that we'd like others to make
donations to so for example my aunt has
asked for donations to the rnli while
pixel girl and i are asking for
donations to a local cancer hospice but
in recommending a charity how can you be
sure that they're really having a
positive impact or that your money's
being well spent you could do a bunch of
research yourself or you could use
givewell who have kindly sponsored this
video givewell is a free-to-use
not-for-profit foundation that spends
over 20 000 hours researching the
efficiency and effectiveness of
charities every year they focus on
recommending charities that help people
the best and can prove they do so via
transparent practices basically they
simplify the process of finding and
donating to outstanding charities in
particular givewell currently recommends
a bunch of charities that do great work
providing health care in the global
south and if you'd like them to allocate
your money where it's needed most you
can donate to the givewell maximum
impact fund if you'd like to join the 50
000 people who have already used
givewell confident in the knowledge that
their donations will be used wisely and
used transparently then givewell are
currently matching donations from first
time donors dollar for dollar up to 250
to donate go to the link in the
description and use the code simon clark
at the checkout to make sure that your
donation gets matched thank you to
givewell for sponsoring this video and
please do donate generously this
christmas
thank you for watching the video i hope
that 2021 treated you kindly and if not
i hope 2022 is better i'd also just like
to take a moment and say thank you
because this is the last video of the
year i want to thank you for making this
my job and for allowing me to hopefully
make the world a better place via these
videos so i wouldn't be here without you
thank you so much for your support if
you'd like some recommended viewing next
then here's some over here you can check
out givewell just below me along with a
subscription button if you're not
already subscribed and that just leads
me to say happy holidays thank you again
for watching i'll see you in the next
one